read
meme ん
コロンらー
そのままでいい
たまにはね
つまずいて転んだらしばらくそのまま
うつ伏せていたい私はそんな子どもでした
潰せていた if な子供でした
転んだらそれはそれで面白いものが見え
ます
地面に色ありは私が思ってた以上に
たくさんの数がいたり
顔に当たると痛いほどの勢いで草が生えて
いたり
医師に入るコケが小さな島のように見え
たり転んだからこそ見えるものがあります
私は幼い頃友達は遊びに誘うのが苦手で
よく一人で遊んでいました
ひとりかくれんぼ
ソファーになりきるソファーごっこ
私にしかわからないルールの遊びを
たくさん作って遊んでいました
地面にうつぶせてそこから見える風景を
眺めるのも私にとってお気に入りの遊びの
一つでした
恋遊びの経験の中で
私はある特技を身に付けました
それは身の回りのものを面白がるという
特技です
目の周りにある変哲のないものをいかに
面白がって楽しくなるかが私が1人で遊ぶ
時のポイントであり
を刺し私の遊びの木もでした
そういうふうに周りのもの面白くがり
ながら生きていたら
変哲もないものとてが本当に面白く見えて
きました
見方を変えれば
つまらないものはないと思っています
みなさん自分の身近な
街でもちょっとなんかつまんないなぁって
思ってしまう街を想像してみてください
自分の家の近所でも地元の町でもどこでも
構いません
皆さんはその街をどんな風に歩いています
か
毎日
同じ時間に同じスピードで同じ目線で歩い
ていますか
もしそうだとしたら何か一つでも変えてみ
てください
新しい発見があるかもしれません
もしくは何かテーマを見つけて歩いてみて
ください
例えば動物をテーマに歩いてみるとします
すると街の中にはそんじょそこらの動物園
に負けないぐらいの数の動物がいるなぁと
いう発見があるかもしれません
また
いつもよりちょっと早く家を出てみて
店がまだ it な時間帯にお店の
シャッターというテーマで歩いてみて
ください
すると
シャッターが閉まっているからこそ見
られるまちの芸術たちに出会えるかもしれ
ません
お店が閉まっている時間でもその前を通る
人たちはお客さんたちを楽しませようとし
ているんだなぁと思って私はその心意気に
嬉しくなります
おもしろがろうと思えば今まで見えなかっ
たものが見えてきます
その風景の裏側にある人の営みや
人たちの企みを垣間見ることもできます
面白がるということは興味を持つという
ことであり
今まで何も感じていなかったような身近な
ものたちをちょっと違う角度から見る
きっかけになるかもしれません
そういうことを考えれば考えるほど私は何
か面白がっている時間がすごく好きだなと
いうふうに思います
そんな私が今面白がっているものをそれは
祖父母です
私はうちのじいちゃんばあちゃん研究と
称して祖父母の歴史をたどっています
そこがどこでどんな風に生まれ育ってと
いう人たちと触れ合って生きてきたのか
曾祖父母やその上の代の人たちがどんな人
だったのか
これを祖父母やその兄弟たちに話を聞き
記録しています
また
祖父母たちのルートをたどって家系図を
作るために
こういうふうに実家の父母たちのそれぞれ
の実家のお墓を巡ったりそれになった親戚
たちに会いに行ったりしています
私がなぜ今うちのじいちゃんばあちゃん
研究をしているのか
私は大学で文化人類学という学問を専攻し
ています
その中でいろんな土地に行ってその土地の
中で生きる人々がどういうふうに生きてき
たのか今どんな風に生活しているのかと
いう話を聞いています
その話一つ一つは本当に興味深くていつも
ワクワクしています
特に私たちの父母に当たるような世代の人
達の話は
世代の人たちの当たり前の日常や
旦那さんとどうやって結婚したんですか
そういう馴れ初めなんかの何でもない話が
私にはとっても楽しいです
興味深いです
6そういう風に感じる楽しかったなぁ
いろんな話聞けたなって思うと同時に
私は
ある引っかかるお前も抱えていました
それは家の
私はいわば赤の他人であるおじいちゃんお
ばあちゃんがどこでどんな風に生まれ育っ
たのか知っているのに自分のじいちゃん
ばあちゃんがどういうふうに生きてきたの
かまったく知らないなって思いです
そこにいるのが当たり前すぎて
私はじいちゃんばあちゃんのことを面白
がったり興味を持つことを後回しにしてい
たように思います
もっとも水面身近にある大切にしたいもの
を面白がることを忘れていました
皆さんにとって大切なものは何ですか
友達家族時間思い出お金
いろいろあると思います
その中で今大切にしたいものは何ですか
私が今大切にしたいものは家族です
特に順番通りに行くと残りの時間が限られ
ている祖父母と過ごす時間を大切にしたい
なと思いました
今までずっと家族のことは大切にしたい
大切にしてるっていうふうに思っていたん
ですけど実際はそう思っているだけで行動
が伴っていませんでした
大切にしたいものを大切にする方法は
たくさんあります
ちょっと一人一人違うはずです
私はこれからもう一度家族と向き合って
私なりの方法で
家族を大切にしていこうと決めました
私が大切にしたいものを大切にする
まず1つめの方法それは
大切にしたいもののことを面白がること
です
うちの爺ちゃん婆ちゃんは
ただ話しているだけでもとても面白いん
ですが
もっと深く知ることができればいろんな
角度からをもしれるんじゃないかと面白
がれるんじゃないかと思って始めたのが
うちのじいちゃんばあちゃん研究です
最初はなかなか昔の話をしてくれなかった
ばあちゃんもこういう風に写真を出したり
とか昔使ってた道具を見せながらお話を
するとどんどん話してくれるようになっ
たり
対話というもののあり方を考えるうえでも
とても勉強になっています
曾曾爺ちゃんは薩摩足軽だったんだよとか
馬に乗るのが好きでよく
馬に乗って田んぼに入ってたんだよとか
今まで私が知った気になっていただけで
全く知らなかったじいちゃんばあちゃんの
いろんな側面を今発見できています
うちの爺ちゃん婆ちゃんは
五人でも有名人でもありません
めまぐるしい時の流れの中ででいつか人々
の記憶から消えていってしまうかもしれ
ない存在です
でも私の中ではかけがえのない存在であり
場所という歴史の中では大事な大事な偉人
です
いずれは私が死んだと思うじいちゃんばあ
ちゃんが生きた記録が残るように何らかの
形で残していきたいなというふうに思って
います
大切にしたいもののことを知って
大切にしたいものを面白がること
そしてそれを何かに残すこと
それが私が大切にしたいものを大切にする
方法です
きっと身の回りにはまだ私が気づいてい
ない面白いものや大切にしたいものが溢れ
ているんだと思います
私はこれからも身の回りのものを面白がっ
て大切にしたいものを大切にしながら生き
ていきたいとおもいます
皆さんは身の回りのどんなものを面白がり
ますか
みなさんはどんな方法で大切にしたいもの
を大切にしますか